maya me carbo c'est le nom du véhicule
utilitaire commandé par suède à citroën
pour son site de saint cyr l'école où
les eaux usées de la plaine de
versailles sont traités le véhicule ici
en démonstration s'inscrit dans
l'objectif de suez de réduire ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 45%
d'ici 2030
ce véhicule il va servir à à pouvoir
aider nos agents à pouvoir faire des
rondes de surveillance de process sur un
site comme carré de réunions tourner sur
un site relativement grand donc on a des
agents qui surveille que le process
fonctionne correctement le process de
traitement des eaux ça permettra
effectivement de augmenter sa
performance parce que ça va lui
permettre de dédier du temps à faire
aussi autre chose que bah finalement de
se déplacer de point en point à travers
ce site accessible et utilisable sans
permis maya mi cargo est homologué
quadricycles légers au prix de 7000
euros il a une capacité d'autonomie des
75 km c'est un objet de mobilité
innovants destinés aux professionnels
ils innovent parce que il est d'abord
dans un gabarit inhabituel extrêmement
compact agile de m 41 delon simplement
il est 100% électrique dans les les
enjeux importants pour nos clients il ya
le fait que l'on cherche à proposer une
solution de mobilité pour tous qui
permet d'aller partout et aujourd'hui on
voit bien que plus en plus de villes
impose des restrictions dans certains
quartiers pour les véhicules qui ne sont
pas électrifiés citroën a enregistré
plus de 4000 commandes et suez envisage
un déploiement rapide du quadricycle sur
ces sites
dès la livraison les huiles se fait
partie de paris métropole donc ça sera
déployée dans cette région là le premier
véhicule utilitaire maya mi cargo
devrait arriver sur le site de saint cyr
l'école dans les prochaines semaines